Ever hear somebody say, “Whiskey makes you
frisky?”
“Gin makes you sin.”
“Wine makes you divine.”
“Tequila makes you fight everybody.”
Do different liquors really have different
effects?
Hello!
Julian here for DNews from YouTube Space LA.
It’s one of those longstanding “facts”
everyone knows about alcohol: different liquors
make you act differently.
Give someone a gin and tonic and you’re
in for a long night of red-faced tear-fueled
soul searching.
Give that same person tequila and they’re
Macho Man Randy Savage, oh yeah!
But is it… y’know… true?
Does one liquor have that special something
in it that turns on rage mode that others
lack?
According to science, drumroll please….
No.
Nope.
There’s no reason vodka or gin or tequila
or whiskey or wine or beer or absynth should
make you behave differently provided you’re
drinking the same amount of alcohol.
Alcohol and liquor are often used synonymously
but alcohol is just a molecule in liquors
and it doesn’t change from one booze to
the next.
They all use yeast in the fermentation process,
and once the yeast process sugar for energy,
their waste product is that familiar maker
of nights and ruiner of mornings: ethanol.
Yes, alcohol is the same compound added to
gasoline to make it more explosive.
Just a reminder that the same chemicals or
molecules can have multiple applications.
*cough* anti-vaxxers *cough*
But clearly different liquors taste differently,
do any of those flavors affect behavior?
There’s no scientific data to back that
up.
Darker liquors have more congeners in them
that make hangovers worse, but there’s nothing
that points to them affecting the pre-hangover
stage.
In fact a study from 1970 monitored 8 men.
4 of them drank bourbon for 9 days and then
switched to vodka for another 9, while the
other 4 started on a 86 proof liquor that
was mixed with caramel and then switched to
bourbon.
Regardless of the liquor or congeners added,
they all behaved the same; starting off more
sociable, and then becoming more depressed
and hostile as they continued to drink.
But then how do you explain all these anecdotes
of people who say, “Oh I can’t have whiskey,
last time I had whiskey I robbed a zoo?”
It’s probably all in your head.
People on alcohol are suggestible.
In fact, they’re even suggestible when they
just think they’ve been drinking.
A 2003 study gave some participants vodka
and others flat tonic water labeled as vodka,
and both of them were just as easily mislead
when asked to remember an event.
And yes, there was a control who were told
they drank flat tonic water.
They did much better on the test.
So really the effect liquor has on you is
linked to its reputation or situation: tequila
is claimed to make people rowdy, so when people
drink it they’re probably looking to get
rowdy and then they, unsurprisingly, get rowdy.
Champagne is often drunk at festive occasions,
so it’s more likely to put people in a bubbly
mood.
Likewise if you’re in a bad mood and you
start drinking any liquor, you’re gonna
have a bad time.
It could be linked to past experiences too;
if you had a great night and happened to be
drinking vodka, you’ll likely opt for vodka
as your booze of choice.
Familiarity with the drink is important too,
in a 1997 study one group of people were given
beer, another group was given a blue peppermint
concoction with the same alcohol content as
beer, and people on the peppermint reported
themselves as drunker while performing worse
on cognitive and motor tasks.
It’s really just a placebo effect, or more
accurately, a nocebo effect, which is like
a placebo effect, but with a negative spin
to it.
So if you’ve been blaming one liquor or
another for bad decisions or bad behavior,
it’s not the alcohol’s fault, it’s just
you.
So different alcohols don’t actually make
you different kinds of drunk, but they definitely
affect where you fall on the hungover spectrum.
Anthony explains why down here.
Check the description if you’re on your
mobile.
Alcohol is a big, huge, multi-sided topic
and there are likely many myths you’re curious
about.
If you want us to cover one, let us know in
the comments.
And a friendly reminder: if you choose to
drink, be safe and smart about it.
I’ll see you next time on DNews.